you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
it's day two of president biden's
climate summit we speak to the european
commissioner for climate action
about the eu's targets
china is undertaking the world's largest
environmental migration project
to tackle the impact of climate change
on rural communities
and tomorrow the climate live festival
kicks off with 24 hours of global
youth-led concerts we hear from
singer-songwriter
declan mckenna who's taking part
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and we aim to take you to the
heart of the climate crisis
explain the data driving the changes
that are already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come
and it's the second day of the american
convened leader summit on climate change
and today
president biden said great progress had
been made
but it was only a start well coming up
we'll have all the key developments from
day two of the summit
but many of the main announcements were
made by countries ahead of the main
meeting taking place including
a target from the eu to cut carbon
emissions by at least
55 by 2030 compared with 1990 levels
well earlier i spoke to the european
commissioner for climate action
france timmermans the eu has agreed to
cut its emissions by 55
by 2030 the european parliament wanted
60 so have you settled for two smaller
cuts
well i think we've we've found a way out
that would
um allow council to agree with it and
parliament to see that it
got out of these negotiations because
now we can also
operate with a so-called carbon budget
which will make it clearer
how much we're using up of the room we
have we have more clarity on our
trajectory to 2040
and 2050 we'll have a greater influence
of scientific evidence in our decision
making
and that's all thanks to the negotiating
powers of parliament so
i think at the end of the day everybody
was very happy with the result
and yet some would say that 55 doesn't
go far enough
independent scientific analysts climate
action tracker for example says the eu
would need to set a target of
65 percent not 55 percent and fund
climate action abroad in order to have
commitments that are compatible with the
paris agreement
apart from the uk there's nobody else
on the planet that is doing as much as
the eu is doing
so in that sense i believe we're we're
together with the uk
we're setting a trend and now others are
following like united states and
hopefully also
other big emitters such as china will
follow a suit
and i believe if you put all these
efforts together
we could we could really get to climate
neutrality by the middle of the century
and i think
i think um we need to start immediately
and uh what we've done with the climate
law
compels the european union to stick to
that trajectory and i i believe
uh this is is is what needs to be done
also by other major emitters
at the end of the day frankly i don't
care who wins i mean everybody wins and
if the uk is ahead of the eu
good for them but we'll see each other
in 2050 and hopefully
both we will reach climate neutrality by
then
and you can see our full interview with
friends timmermans youtube.com
sky news let's take a look now at some
of the day's other climate news
and day two of the u.s president's
climate summit has been focusing on how
technology can help the world achieve a
net zero
climate-resilient economy joe biden
wants to spend
trillions of dollars on clean energy
technology to boost the us economy
and help create jobs while saving the
planet speakers at the summit today have
included bill gates michael bloomberg
and business executives
extinction rebellion activists have
dumped fake coal
outside the lloyd's headquarters in
london campaigners say
it's part of ongoing protests aimed at
exposing the insurance industry and its
investment in fossil fuel companies
lloyds of london says it plans to phase
out all existing insurance policies for
fossil fuel projects
by 2030.
[Applause]
scientists say crops could be naturally
modified to make them more resistant to
climate change
researchers found grass crops like wheat
can borrow genes from other species
the process known as lateral gene
transfer enables them to speed up
evolution
and adapt to new environments more
quickly
[Applause]
it looks set to be one of the driest
aprils on record the met office says
there's been an average of 12.8
millimeters of rain across the uk so far
this month
that's just 18 of average levels
it comes after the uk recorded the
coldest start to april
since 2013.
[Applause]
the habitats of endangered chimpanzees
will be studied by researchers at the
university of
leicester laser scanners are going to be
used to create
three-dimensional images of the primates
nests in the congo
the project will look at the forest and
woodlands in the nature reserve where
they live
climate change is driving migration
around the world
and in china's agricultural rural
communities
droughts in the northwest of the country
have become more frequent
they used to happen every four years but
since 1991
they now happen in this region every two
years in ningxia over the past
60 years temperatures have risen by 2.1
degrees
celsius with more than half of that
increase taking place
from 2001 to 2010. as a result more than
a million farmers have migrated
from the south to the north to the much
better
irrigated basin of the yellow river our
asia correspondent tom cheshire reports
now
from northwest china
[Applause]
this was once a thriving village
shihaiku in ningxia
north west china the un has described
this as one of the most
uninhabitable places in the world people
here still leaked out in existence for
years
carving homes out of the hills but
temperatures have risen two degrees over
the last half century
that's twice as fast as the global
average and a similar rise to what the
world is trying to avoid
with the paris climate agreement the
land simply could no longer
support the people who lived on it so
the village was abandoned
its houses destroyed this is a ghost
village and well it might look like a
relic of the past
it could be a glimpse of the future as
climate migration takes hold
worldwide this was always a tough place
to live but climate change
made it impossible the government
removed the last of the villagers in
2020
they went to this new town several
hundred miles north
they still need to work hard in the
fields but irrigation that was
impossible down south makes agriculture
here
much more reliable
mrs ma used to live in one of those cave
houses in shihaiku
and was one of the first to come here
around 20 years ago
[Music]
china is the world's biggest polluter
and it's already having to deal with the
effects of climate change
the same may be in store for the rest of
the world if it fails to meet its
targets
tom cheshire sky news ningxia teaching
children about climate change
isn't part of the national curriculum in
any country except italy
but a new international effort has been
launched to educate
three to seven-year-olds on sustainable
habits
it's called the earth warriors scheme
and dominic bond and his son billy are
taking part
are you an earth warrior yeah i am what
do you do when you're being an earth
warrior
i saved earth how do you help to save
the earth
by not catching by not using fish
by not using fish i mean not eating fish
okay well schweiterbari co-founded earth
warriors and she thinks education
is a powerful tool for combating climate
change
giving children the opportunity and the
knowledge that they need
to know about climate change the things
that they can do to combat it in the
future can
really empower them to be the future
change makers
it's not about teaching them anything
complex or scary
and it's very much framed in a positive
way around
building their love and bond with nature
now i just want to show you the
real-time power mix for great britain
because over the last couple of days
we've seen some of the highest solar
generation
levels of the year and the forecast for
this weekend is for near record levels
of solar power
wind generation remains low so overall
renewable output is around
one-third of the generation mix you can
see 38
there now solar power tends to be the
highest in spring
rather than summer when you might expect
it and that's because solar panels
perform better
in cooler temperatures now tomorrow
youth climate groups from around the
world will come together to launch
climate live
there'll be 24 hours of live music
streams with artists
activists and scientists all taking part
it's hoped the performances will help
unite people and reach those who aren't
currently engaged in the crisis
well earlier i spoke to singer declan
mckenna who's performing a special live
set for the event
for a long time now i've been feeling
the climate crisis is
has been vital for me to speak up about
and for me to be a part of campaigning
for
um and right now uh
really the important thing for me um is
holding the government
our government particularly supercam um
to
keeping you know global temperatures uh
below a 1.5 degree
increase i think that is a massively
important goal we're seeing the impacts
of
um you know pollution and rising
temperatures worldwide and
people are already suffering and what
about in terms of changing attitudes do
you feel that they
are changing i mean or do you think it's
a generational thing
what's your opinion it is one thing for
us individuals to make changes to our
lifestyle
and demand things it is another for our
governments
and our you know the systems that play
to to change
and to um become sustainable for
our future on this planet um so yes the
attitudes i i think even seeing the last
five years
um i've been very much engaged and you
know the change has been very obvious
obvious in
in our attitudes it's it's whether it
can
materialize with you know within within
the government
this year marks the 51st earth day the
world's largest environmental campaign
so let's take a look at how people
around the world have been celebrating
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
well that's it for today's show but you
can get your climate fix over the
weekend with our podcast
on this week's episode more on those
earth day celebrations around the world
and what we learned from the leaders
climate summit hosted by president biden
climate cast is available wherever you
normally get your podcast from and of
course you can watch our weekly digital
show with becky cottrell on sky news
social channels our app
and our website thanks for watching and
we'll see you next week
you